right because it doesn't didn't sound
like you had a stage parent it was like
on your back like okay nobody knew
anything I didn't know anyway right my
drama teacher didn't know anyway you
know I mean I learned I learned as I
went I mean I as a little kid I
I thought movies were reality shows I
didn't know what reality shows were but
I thought that Hollywood people would
find somebody really cool and then they
would just follow them around and that's
what a movie was so in a way I'm this
person that came up with reality TV
before it happened
but no I you know I I thought that's
what that was and then I found out that
you know that was a job that was an
actor and that was a job you could get
and so I remember saying to my family
yeah I want to be an actor and then
after they got finished laughing uh it
was just something that was so far out
of my reach in their opinion that became
my opinion you know but then I got to
high school my drama teacher made it
more of a real possibility in my head
again so I decided to go for it
did you even have headshots in high
school yeah when they took you down - no
you know it worked different then you
know you it's harder now because there's
a lot of stuff when you're starting out
you've got to do on your own back in the
day you know you do to find managers and
agents who would actually promote and
and and help sort of develop a career
and that's a much harder thing to find
nowadays so you end up with places like
backstage and and actors access and you
know actors are now having to find ways
to develop their own careers and start
their own stuff
so yeah I didn't really have pictures or
anything until my agent was like you
gotta have pictures so so then they
hooked you up with someone here in
Ventura take no no no when I once I got
to Los Angeles everything happened in
Los Angeles you know my agent
took me to an LA photographer everything
was there everything happened in LA back
then you had to move to one of the hubs
and you had LA or New York and you know
that's where the career was that's where
the industry was that's where you needed
to be obviously now it's different you
know there's more hubs first of all and
there's just more access to things
because folks all over the country all
the world are making films they're
finding each other through the internet
and sites like this so there's a lot
more opportunity to start now then was
then but just oh pretty exciting that
you know be a 16 year old kid and in Los
Angeles all the time it was pretty
awesome how soon did you start working
after that I think I got my first gig
about a year in I did a play at the latc
and it was at that play that I ran into
a casting director who was casting she
worked for Steven Bochco and they asked
me to audition for Doogie Howser and so
that's how that happened and that was
fun
once that audition happened how quickly
and how much did your life change
immediately link mediate because you
kind of go from like you're just a face
in the crowd you're just another picture
you know and now Steven Bochco
you're like his latest find so now
everyone's really interested in who the
hell you are you know what I mean so
it's an immediate switch and that was
then
No now the way the fame celebrity
machine works I'm sure when folks get on
shows nowadays they're so there's so
much more to do with regard to you know
publicity and all of that stuff we did a
lot but nothing compared to what happens
now so you moved down to LA of course to
be on the show or okay and then are you
also taking classes and doing other
things in addition to be on the show or
I had been taking classes on a
consistent basis up until I started the
show at that point I just didn't have
the time we were we had like 6 a.m.
calls and we would work you know 12 14
hour days and we were working every day
during the week because you know we were
a single camera show so it was shot
similar to a feature
unlike sitcoms which are awesome
schedule wise it's really a lot less but
yeah we were just we're just going and
going so my real training really kind of
kicked in when I started doing the show
and working with these people who are
veterans and you know I've been doing
things for way longer than I had and I
think that was a real big learning
process because I was there on set you
got to make it happen you know what I
mean yeah he get takes but still there's
a big difference between you know acting
on a stage and a class you know that you
you paid for and being on a set where
the time is equivalent to money and you
are spending money and it's important
that things get done correctly it's a
big difference big big difference
you